[Music]
welcome back let's check in with rocky
and tobin auto group the sponsors of
this next segment on how they're helping
the great toy drive this holiday season
all right before we get into giving back
hiram i got to know what's on your
christmas list rocky i think i have
everything that's on my christmas list i
have a beautiful family at home a
three-year-old a five-year-old i have
everything that anyone could ask for and
a great employer that's always giving
back always contributing i'm blessed wow
that's what it's all about gratitude
right have you started your christmas
shopping for those two kids
rocky i've been procrastinated a little
bit but we took priority and find some
kids for the kids at shade tree and this
is actually one of the um toys that my
son picked out to give to the kids at
shade trees starting them early in fact
that is beautiful so let's talk about
the kids that will be benefiting from
what your kids are bringing to the to
the boxes yeah so we are donating toys
to the shae tree which is an
organization that
helps battered kids and battered women
and we are so grateful to contribute to
them and for every toy that
the people bring in uh chap's actually
gonna match it one for one so we're
gonna double these toys and we're gonna
make a bunch of kids happy and chop is
the owner of the tobin auto group so
doing so much for the community as
always so what kind of toys are you guys
looking for what can we bring i have
barbie here and i got bay blades and we
got mr potato have any unopened toys
rocky
anything that you guys can contribute uh
would help greatly okay okay and we can
do this until december 15th at each of
your locations here in the valley autumn
mall tell them which locations so
any location in the tobin auto group we
have tobin kia
tobin alfa romeo and fia and then we are
in the od store tobin dodge
store
you guys have been in town here since
1998
yep 1998. bringing joy to the community
adults alike as well as the kids because
you guys have been giving us amazing
cars for so long yeah of course of
course and we we're happy to to provide
such a great experience for the
customers the kids come in they have fun
the dogs come in they have fun so that's
what it's all about we're just gonna
have a bunch of fun this holiday season
well speaking of fun you know after you
come in and you buy a car or you donate
your gift
you gotta hit the gong okay
so make sure you come down to the valley
auto mall between now and december 15th
donate your toys talk to hiram find him
and get all the information you need
i'll send it back to you
our great toy drive continues with the
help of tobin auto group and telus
international you can drop off a new
unwrapped toy or even a gift card at any
of the dealerships on your screen the
donations will benefit the shade tree
organization